breaking tonight concerns over the delta
variant and what is happening with the
possibility of booster shots not only
for the immune compromise but possibly
for everybody is that on the
the front burner let's bring in dr
francis collins director of the national
institutes of health thank you sir for
being here
glad to be with you and to talk about
these things brett yeah it's important
people have a lot of questions peter
referenced it in his uh piece it was an
axios piece that was titled biden's big
cova challenge fading vaccines may
demand boosters here's how they quote it
i think everybody believes this wanes
over time the question is to what extent
according to a senior biden official
that debate has hamstrung by a severe
lack of clear data from the cdc even top
administration officials can't get the
information they want making it harder
to assess when boosters will be needed
and for whom the vaccines are still
having a positive effect but we're
painting this train as it's going
180 miles an hour said michael osterhome
director of the center for infectious
disease research and policy so
are you confident that these vaccines
can last beyond six months
well they look good up until six months
let's be clear about that we've got lots
of data to show that even at six months
the efficacy against uh severe disease
hospitalization is in the 90-plus
percent so that's all good but delta has
thrown another wrinkle in here and so we
now have to really look and see with
delta now becoming the vast majority of
virus isolates in the u.s
is that going to affect the way in which
this slow waning of immune response is
going to be necessary to address i can
assure you and everybody watching that
this is a topic of intense daily
investigation by the fda the cdc the nih
and others looking at every bit of data
we can get our hands on from the u.s
from other countries trying to assess
exactly what's the right decision to
make but as of right now it looks as if
even with delta our current vaccines are
holding up really well but watch this
space we're going to be checking this
very very frequently over the next few
weeks so right now a booster for someone
who's immune compromised but possibility
that we all
get boosters come the fall
well i'm glad you mentioned the immuno
compromised clearly we do want to help
those folks who have not been able to
raise an adequate immune response from
the standard dosing and there is clearly
an effort to try to make that possible a
sap and that is a separate circumstance
those aren't people who sort of needed a
booster after six months they're people
whose initial immunization didn't quite
take for the rest of us well maybe this
fall i think all of us looking at the
data will say boosters are going to be
necessary at some point the question is
what's the right timing that's what
we're really working to try to define
from the most rigorous science that we
can get our hands on it seems like
there's a little frustration about
getting the data at least privately from
from the administration officials the
policymakers um
but
can you definitively say to somebody
that
the vaccine provides better protection
than the antibodies that you get from
actually having had covet 19.
yes brett i can say that
there was a study published by cdc uh
just 10 days ago in kentucky and they
looked specifically at people who had
had natural infection and people who'd
been vaccinated
and then ended up getting infected again
so what was the protection level it was
more than twofold better from the people
who had the vaccine in terms of
protection than people who'd had the
natural infection that's very clear in
that kentucky study
you know that surprises people kind of
surprised me that the vaccine would
actually be better than natural
infection but if you think about it kind
of makes sense the natural infection
kind of gets into your nose and your
airway the systemic vaccine gets more of
your immune system engaged and
apparently does a better job of
preparing you if you're going to see
that virus again you said that data
settled issue data from all over
including overseas the wall street
journal cites the uk data could be a
positive indication saying the latest
surge of covet 19 cases in uk is giving
rise to growing optimism among doctors
and scientists that the highly
transmissible delta variant of the
coronavirus can be held at bay with high
levels of vaccination and public caution
although case loads are now ticking
higher hospital admissions have been
falling deaths are a fraction of the
level seen in earlier phases of the
pandemic in other words the u.k other
places had seen a major spike but that
is really falling off
as time goes on is that what we are to
look forward to
well one would hope i think it's really
hard to extrapolate from other countries
experience and you know i'm a little
concerned when i saw the uk spike come
down fairly quickly i was encouraged but
look at the last week or so it stopped
going down and it looks like it might be
going back up again this virus has so
many tricks that we haven't completely
figured out you know the bottom line
brett is if we in the united states want
to avoid more cases more
hospitalizations more deaths if there
was ever a wake-up call for the people
who have not gotten vaccinated yet this
is the moment find out how to get that
vaccine there's a place near you that
has it ready it's free it's available
there's no time to waste and we put that
up every day uh dr collins last thing
you know as more and more information
comes out um i remember your skepticism
the emails you sent dr fauci at the
beginning and we've gone over that we've
asked you that about
the covet origins and
the skepticism about it coming from the
lab and you clarified that you thought
it was
not a weaponized thing from the chinese
but that it may have been a lab accident
it seems more and more pointing that way
are you confident saying that or or
closer to that
you know i don't think i have any more
new information to be able to tip the
balance certainly possible that this was
somehow understudy in the lab even
though it was not human engineered from
scratch i'm quite confident of that but
how do we know the yeses or no's i've
looked at the report certainly from the
house committee i think we're all
waiting in the next two weeks to hear
what the national intelligence
study is going to come up with we've
cooperated with them we've answered lots
of their questions give them lots of
technical advice but i'm not privy to
what their conclusion is going to be and
that'll be really important it will and
dr collins we appreciate your time
you're welcome back anytime